le Loir-et-Cher c'est près de 3400 km de
route bordée de fossés en herbées
l'herbe trop haute peut constituer un
danger pour la visibilité des
conducteurs ou propager un incendie en
cas de mégot lancé par des
automobilistes imprudents le fauchage
est donc nécessaire pourtant aujourd'hui
on reconnaît qu'il a produit qui la
pauvrit la biodiversité locale et
entraîne une érosion des sols il
convient donc de limiter le nombre des
interventions et c'est ce que nous
explique romain Delville
la première mission des agents faucheurs
du conseil départemental de Loir-et-Cher
ces deux fauchées en toute sécurité
parce que sur une ligne droite comme
celle-ci la visibilité est bonne mais
l'impatience voir l'inconscience des
automobilistes agissent aussi sur les
routes sinueuses
qui double sans forcément avoir le temps
du coup
c'est un peu dangereux pour nous après
là il va être mis en place un
de protection sur les axes
à grandir la sécurité des agents et des
usagers de la route c'est une constante
mais ce qui a changé cette année sur les
3000 km de route loir-et-chérienne c'est
que le fauchage estonné les hauteurs de
coupe qui ont été surélevés avec des
largeurs de coupe qui ont aussi été
réduites et de la périodicité qui prend
en compte plus le temps et les
conditions de développement de la
végétation de mai à février prochain il
y aura trois passages avec les épareuses
l'idée c'est d'intervenir au bon moment
et plus seulement selon un calendrier
déterminé
en trouvant l'équilibre entre préserver
les enjeux de sécurité routière parce
que ça c'est ce qui prévaut dans notre
démarche c'est c'est l'essentiel et de
couper au bon moment où la végétation a
atteint une croissance pour justement
limiter sa repousse dans un second temps
et et là on demain on sera amené à
trouver cet équilibre et c'est
l'expérience qui va nous amener à
déclencher au moment propice autre
avantage d'un fauchage qui n'est plus au
ras du sol il y a moins de casse
matériel les outils de coupe rencontrent
par définition moins d'obstacles